c'est à l'âge de 11 ans que mes choix
commencé à chanter de son père musicien
elle a hérité d'une sensibilité musicale
que le public réunionnais apprécié
depuis presque trente ans maintenant
petit frère l'escalier parce que nous
c'était soit 166 attend 63 64 65 66 est
le petit frère de sa s'est ému
spectateurs - ouvrez les chaînes ni
monter dessus et puis chanter et multi
frais à policer donc c'était comme ça
m'a dit papa tu y vois que tout en me
aimé chanter tout cela et puis
finalement et jules tiapé a laissé un
petit coucou chanter un petit truc comme
me dit pas passionnant benchikha dont
les aïeux rappel le premier mot société
du grand avignon comment les gars y
sommes je sais que ça et puis revient
morceaux de doigté fait
kaffrine n'y aura pas d'appel
d'affronter fille bien dans ces gars
piquet fils inti ninna nanna alors mon
ventilateur est karine karine
karine
après avoir consacré quelques années à
sa petite famille mais je retrouve la
scène en 96 aujourd'hui elle célèbre la
sortie d'un troisième album intitulé mon
coeur mon pays plus qu'un symbole
il fait à manger des manceaux en plus
pour un spectacle par exemple même si
paris mange pas aussi bien que lot d or
la ville ou navette on n'avait pas
besoin de ces promotions pour qu'un
disque i marsh et ben ils ferment
toujours un plus parce que ici vraiment
à faire un spectacle d'autres nouveaux
morceaux et n'oublie toujours parle par
exemple de ce qui bouscule par des lots
la saillie il reste toujours la salle
aglaé reste dans mon programme mais
toujours est il que les nappes toujours
par rapport au disque qui sonne a
toujours un des nouveautés et que les
bons par exemple de justice justice pour
gagner saucisses ou mélodica courants
d'air ça ira mais n'est plus quand même
à chaque fois
à chaque fois c'est pas la grosse
émotion en fait ils dépendent eux des
podiums c'est à dire aujourd'hui nous
les miels vers demain nous aurait fait
du gingembre après nous pour être pas au
et dépend de la situation est tranquille
et bien là les mois près de trappes
oh
et
bien c'est celle au que malgré tout les
monceaux tous mes cd en fait de la
fécule et manceau depuis 96 jusque là
mais cette année à l'assentiment de mon
nouveau l'amour que mon pays c'est
monsieur honoré l'a fait quelques textes
est d'ailleurs très comique comme par
exemple justice pont des saucisses ou
bien et puis dans une autre chanson
n'est pas mal non plus et lille défi est
très bien il parle du métissage et tout
ça
les thèmes abordés dans la plupart des
morceaux c'est l'écologie
l'amitié l'amour certainement parce que
avec coo de doux c'est bon
c'est la mode et de deux êtres
mais pas contre le jour où n'est pas
quelles musiques
venues d'ailleurs qui ont envahi notre
pays
mais ma conseils de gens de rester quand
même de notre culture c'est à dire le
cigare le maloya comme dit fier mais où
quelqu'un danyel waro basse-terre enfin
jusqu'à quand c'est la culture
réunionnaise reste là dedans c'est ça
mon conseil allez pas lieu at paix dans
le pays
michaud fait également le lapierre la
grande scène parisienne c'était
dangereux 90 et l'océan indien était
fortement 2,7 g tinal castien giardino
et beaucoup d'autres encore
le lay ps et ses pires que la eu
l'initiative parce que les deux premiers
cd désordre la ville et piment bien
force et pyros que la l'enregistra nous
donc comme nous le faisait partie du
catalogue de pyros c'est lui que l'a
pris en mai tout c'est à dire le voyage
l'hébergement
ah oui oui c'était une salle assez
comble surtout le lendemain parce que le
vendredi l'avait un peu moins étant
donné que les gens là-bas y travaillent
le samedi la plupart donc le samedi
était bloquée et les gens étaient
tellement contents a dit il faut refaire
un jour
vous l'avez affaire
ti-cats courants d'air
on pêche tout cette incroyable énergie
l'énergie est au sommet est mais masao
ma fille kostek ma famille vient de
lever parce que je vomis voir mon bon
café avant après là j'avais démarre mais
bon après mais l'énergie vient bon
peut-être pas ce que signifie un peu de
sport et me dégage tout ça dans pendant
une heure deux fois par semaine
peut-être ça mais bon ces mondiaux si
adam -5 son
épouse maman chanteuse secrétaire de
combinaisons qui nécessite pas mal
d'aménagements
cependant il
n'a quand même des problèmes concernant
les enfants par exemple il lui doit
aller jouer quelque part ou même il
allait enregistrer ou bien pour jouer il
faut répéter donc il faut déposer ses
enfants là et s'ils avaient pas
lémanique l'été là
d'ailleurs c'est vraiment met à
l'honneur aujourd'hui c'est les grands
parents qui jouent un rôle là dedans et
qui aident à nous beaucoup beaucoup la
femme réunionnaise en l'an 2000 a
beaucoup changé et les nappes beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes non les a quand même
un quota assez important dans le qui
soit dans le domaine
de politique surtout le sportif
artistique bien sûr
bon ben mis en oeuvre ajoute un petit
refrain pour toutes les femmes qui soit
la réunion ailleurs et bel été sur mon
disque piment bien fort et c'est pas en
créole ainsi au frein jusqu'à 2 comme sa
femme crée une déesse moût si la terre
pas frivole mais séduction nous à faire
quand on l'a connu à nous ils n'oublient
jamais ils vont toujours notre qualité
femmes créée au hit-parade l'élégance
vrai symbole celui-là union il est temps
ce break n'évolue qu'en dans le coeur
cela m a nou koné nou 2-1
soleil tu as coupé
napper 30 ans en arrière très peu le
taux est au même titre h était un grand
hassan el
ouali authentique est pas mon petit
moment issam assume hp n'était pas
bailliage mail aventure
si les parties
comment nous voir
on y est